hello and welcome to the new world
review your souls for everything anime
and manga and yeah it's Jojo time again
as I share my thoughts on what I would
from anecdotal evidence call the most
controversial part of this whole saga
thing and I could definitely see why
that is and to be perfectly honest
discussing even the most general of
thoughts on stone ocean is going to be a
tricky endeavor you know we'll do our
best anyway but to be clear right from
the beginning my overall impression of
part 6 is very very mixed I don't love
it you don't hate it
and I also haven't had a lot of time to
properly digest it and place it within
the greater context of the series so
this is very much of raw first
impression as everything else has been
things could very much change in the
future and I hope they do
he goes my god do I need some clarity on
my thoughts but let's start out as
simply as possible by saying that from
all of the comments I read I was
expecting stone ocean to go balls to the
wall right from the beginning and yet
didn't do that and in fact
three-quarters of the series follows the
exact same Jojo formula that we've had
going since Stardust Crusaders just
applied to yet another different setting
and that brings us to the first thing
that I did not particularly enjoy
because look prison stories are hard
because their setting is naturally
oppressive flat and devoid of most
sources of visual interest due to being
a facility designed for punishment
rather than comfort the architecture was
uninspiring and as a general backdrop
for the large majority of the action
it's just nothing compared to prior
giorgo incarnations and that's
especially true coming right off golden
wind which use the setting of Italy to
perfection and even pot for which
created this lovely quickie small town
with a surprising amount of variance but
as for stone Ocean the location just
doesn't feel inspired enough to me and
to be fair I should point out that I
always have a strong preference for
stylization hyper realism which part six
does phenomenally when it comes to its
characters but the location look it may
as well have just been a blank canvas
there were points where I felt why even
bother having a background at all and if
you're asking me well how do you propose
to make a prison story that isn't just a
flat jail wall then I would like to
forward you onto the impelled down Ark
of one piece because it can be done and
it can be done very very well
but to make up for the atmosphere stone
ocean instead delivers another fantastic
cast of characters helmed by one Jolene
Cujo who as many of you predicted and I
kind of love kind of because she has her
issues and she falls into the same Jojo
trap as every protagonist before her as
the story inside characters tend to ever
take her a lot but at the same time I
really enjoy Jolene's blunt to NASA
I will say that I was incredibly hyped
for her at the beginning though because
stone ocean initially presents us as a
classic prison revenge story where
everything seems set up for Jolene to
escape and ultimately take revenge on
Romeo kind of Kill Bill style and that
moment where she used her stand to
completely just murder the lawyer who
had misled her into this position was
incredibly gratifying so yes I was all
on board for a revenge story but then
things very suddenly change as it is
discovered that none of that matters and
from here on out this is going to be
mostly about Jolene saving her father
and I do think that's a bit of a shame
because it took the emphasis off this
being a quest for Jolene and put her in
more of a passive position needing to
save someone rather than do something
because she wanted to do it which you
know as much as I stated I wasn't a huge
fan of Jono and part five one of the
things I will give him is that he was
profoundly driven towards his own goal
whereas Jolene to me felt like someone
who has just swept up in something much
much larger than her now as for the
extended cast generally great all-around
and I want to first up give a special
mention to Foo Fighters because I for
one never thought that I would encounter
a colony of plankton that would form a
captivating character on any level much
less one that I would actually mourn the
death of but Foo Fighters was delightful
the plankton stand provided some
much-needed comic relief within the
group of primarily serious individuals
and just yet helped to break up the
monotony of prison life and also we also
did this successfully to some degree
with his ongoing quest to marry Jolene
at one stage even asking for Joe Torre's
permission in the midst of a climactic
battle but at the same time he was also
quite a terrifying character because I
always had the feeling that if you were
to get even slightly on his bad side
then you know you'd probably be swiftly
murdered but he actually becomes
surprisingly touching in the grand
scheme of things and the way his twist
of of Jolene manifests itself as a grand
sacrifice is creepily moving and moving
on I cannot and will never take a man
named weather report seriously which is
tricky because he ends up being quite a
key plot component but every time a
character said something like where's
weather report I couldn't help but
chuckle and yeah whatever I'm sure it
sounds much cooler in Japanese where's
re portal but yeah that's the thing well
they will say is that weather report is
a great name for a stand
not just any stand but one of the most
radically overpowered ones this entire
saga has presented but then again I
found myself saying that about almost
every new stand that was introduced in
stone ocean because some of these powers
is just downright sinister and I'm not
even talking about made in heaven yet
because even Jolene stern free
is pretty absurd but a lot of fun at the
same time and I think Eric you made
fantastic use of the basic concept of
strings but then you also have stuff
like Bohemian Rhapsody which is a stand
that can apparently affect the entire
world bringing fictional characters into
reality and tracking out the souls of
people and tying them to the fate of
said characters I think is insane
I mean it feels like you could almost
have an entire series about this you
know a world where fictional characters
are coming to life and the quest to find
the mystery behind everything but it's
all quite promptly dealt with in seven
tidy chapters I really enjoyed the
concept though and I actually think that
goes for almost every stand-in part six
even the more understated ones and in
fact especially some of the more
understated ones like kiss which is all
about creating duplicates with stickers
and playing with the idea of what you
can do when reforming objects after
removing a sticker with that said not
everything was a hit with me and I will
single out sky high as a stand which had
bored me for a lot of its story I mean
the idea of these mysterious and organic
roads was fascinating but the stand used
to control them and its user which is
kind of mad and it also came at a time
where we were really gunning towards a
conclusion and this became yet another
artificial obstacle to overcome oh oh
and before I move away from Stan's
completely I also want to name-drop
jailhouse lock as quite possibly my
favorite stand ever such a great and
terrifying concept but upon activation a
target can now only learn up to three
new pieces of information and reading
Jolene teal would that was quite
possibly one of the more captivating
experiences I've had with the entirety
of Georgia thus far and there are so so
many other stands that I could mention
and probably just can't remember at the
moment like the dragon one that's all
about feng shui so stands for pot six
were a huge success from my perspective
but let's start to get into the more
controversial stuff aka the last quarter
of stone ocean which goes absolutely
batshit insane and all of this is helped
by the ultimate series protagonist
Enrico Pucci who I will say I enjoyed a
fair bit in fact he's probably my second
favorite big bad guy behind your chicag
Akira at this stage anyway and I liked
his general theme of seeking ascension
and how that blended quite seamlessly
into the jury universe with dioz
influence and just on deer for a second
I think it's kind of crazy that the
brief moments he was featured in part
six actually provides me with a much
more satisfying character than how he
was betrayed in part three because
Stardust Crusaders deer was something of
a flat villain lots of fun but very flat
whereas here he seems capable of
actually being a character dare I say by
developing his relationship with Poochie
and even going so far as to admit a fear
of having could she betray him none of
this was the do I've experienced thus
far that quite like getting to see
another side of him and a lot of that
contributed to how I took to poochie's
motivation because this was a risky
story to tell and very very easily could
have felt like a villain doing villain
things for a dumb villain motive but
instead he does have a very interesting
goal which only becomes apparent once
it's in effect because everything before
that just sounds like babbling about
heaven and stuff it's a super intriguing
idea though basically going to the
effort to create a new universe where
every person has precognitive abilities
thus theoretically removing any sense of
worry and achieving a sense of bliss as
a result at least I think that's the
idea sort of like skipping all of the
stages of human emotion and landing
immediately upon acceptance every time
it is a very cool idea but I do think it
does come a bit out of absolutely
nowhere because part six like I said
plays out like everything else from Part
three onwards until all of a sudden we
are thrust into reshaping the entire
universe and that is a very quick and
very big escalation that I can see would
turn many people off because it may be
taken as a very jump the shark moment
and currently I'm very torn about how I
feel about it personally as a core idea
I love it and I'm happy that the series
built towards this sort of maddening
exploration of humanity but within the
greater context of part 6 I don't know
how well it flows narrative Li stacking
all of this weight within the last I
don't know what 10 15 chapters or so to
me it felt very heavy-handed and not
properly built up towards but I am very
much beginning to understand at this
late stage that that's just our key
sometimes he doesn't conform to
establish storytelling and as a result
some Jojo experiences can feel very
disjointed at times and there's actually
a vivid example of this I can recall
from much earlier in part 6 where Joe
leaned on us we and Foo Fighters
complete their business in the solitary
area in one chapter and then in the very
first page of the next chapter it's just
a hard cut to Jolene and Inasa we had a
doc with this damn yo-yo mast and which
nobody questions the existence of and it
just comes out of nowhere and it's
incredibly jarring it made me feel like
I'd skipped a chapter although there
were pages missing and what I was
reading and sadly enough that's not the
only time that happens in stone ocean
there were many times where I found
myself in a lesser natural progression
moving from chapter to chapter
which I guess is quirky in one way but
maybe annoying in another well there may
be bizarre is the word because there is
the one thing
that I will grant stone ocean 100% in
that it is the very first part to really
embody the namesake of the series this
felt like a bizarre adventure with all
sorts of crazy crap happening like the
protagonist being stuffed into a mouse
corpse a rain of frogs prison zombies
and even a snail apocalypse before we
even get to the meat of the universal
restructuring and another positive I
will give to stone Ocean is that I
really loved how Emporia was the figure
charged with ultimately bringing down
Poochie after everyone else had been
killed the only other figure to transfer
over to the new universe it was a nice
twist because generally that role would
have fallen to Joleen because the Jojo
always defeats the big bad right
turns out no not in this case anyway but
in the end I don't think I really have a
solid opinion of stone ocean yet there
were parts I really enjoyed and there
were parts I really didn't and the
conclusion left me and more of a state
of what the [ __ ] than anything else like
I don't know if I'm happy that our
protagonist now have a much better life
or sad because they lost what they once
were and that goes for the series as a
whole as well because I'm assuming that
everything we've built over these six
parts has now gone entirely or at the
very least different and that's kind of
tricky because I don't know if I feel
like I've wasted my time or if I'm
incredibly excited for something very
new or a mixture of both
I don't know stone Ocean is going to
need a fair bit more time to sit with me
but in the meantime we may as well plow
through to part 7 steel ball run and
I've heard nothing about this part
except that people by and large seem to
rate it almost extraordinarily high so
my hopes are pretty good going into this
one though I can't really tell what kind
of genre it's going to take from this
image alone but whatever let's give it a
go and that pretty much does it for my
muddled and disjointed thoughts on story
notion if you enjoyed this video in the
content this channel produce in general
and please do consider donating to the
new world review patreon because the
support of all of you amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps both this channel and incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server or a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on story notion this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]